Game of Thrones Seasons 1 to 6, in 5 minutes.
Robert Baratheon rules the realm of Westeros
–
he deposed the dragon dynasty and married
a Lannister, Cersei,
who breeds a brood of bastards with her brother
Jaime,
who breaks Bran's back to keep the secret.
Lady Cat captures Tyrion, falsely accuses
him,
Lysa tries to make him fly but Bronn's blade
excuses him.
Ned starts to see that the seed is strong,
so he tries to tell Bobby
but he’s gored by a boar cause of Cersei,
so Ned tries to set shit straight, but Baelish
betrays him
and Ned gets beheaded on the steps of Baelor's
Sept.
Young Robb gathers the banners, battles south,
and is crowned.
Arya trains then runs away, Sansa suffers
Joff and the Hound.
While Jon joins the watch on the Wall, where
winter is falling and wildlings are calling
and walkers are stalking and dead men are
walking.
And Dany weds Drogo, her brother goes loco,
crowned with gold – oh and Drogo dies too.
Dany raises a pyre and strides into fire and
rises as the mother of dragons
Robb battles Lannisters, falls in love with
Talisa –
which breaks his oath to Walder Frey and he
ain't bloody having that
Theon takes a boat to Balon, turns his cloak
to make him Greyjoy
Takes Winterfell, loses it, and Ramsay Snow
abuses him
Bran and Rickon get away – Bran goes with
Jojen – there's a crow
While Stannis claims the Iron Throne, though
his claim's denied by his bro,
so Renly's shanked by a shadow fired from
the vagina of a priestess of fire.
Stannis then sails for Blackwater Bay, but
he's set aflame and loses the day,
Tyrion loses face – but he's still loved
by Shae at the end of the day so its okay
Arya walks with Yoren, but she’s caught
and hauled to Harrenhal.
It’s awful but she's supported by an assassin
called Jaqen H'ghar
Dany walks the Waste and talks Thirteen Qartheen
to let her in to their city.
Goes to a party, asks for an army – Xaro
and Pyat Pree steal her dragons,
so she goes to the home of Undying, gets high,
and kills a guy with fire.
While the Watchmen walk beyond the Wall, and
Qhorin forces Jon to turn his cloak to the
free folk.
So while the Watch is fighting wights and
things, Jon's spooning ginger wildlings, hashtag
No Ygrittes – also there's an army of the
dead.
Cat sends Jaime with Brienne to the south,
then Locke captures them and lops off Jaime’s
hand – ouch
The Freys get fed up, so Robb gets Red Wedded
Killing Cat and Talisa while Edmure's getting
bedded
Arya is captured by bros with no banners,
the Hound fights a fire knight who rises after
battle.
Arya takes flight, but is caught by Sandor
who hauls her round the river lands, hoping
for a ransom
Jon meets Mance, the wildling king fighting
for free folk
They climb the Wall, Jon kills a warg then
goes back to the Night's Watch
Dany gets Unsullied, Selmy, Daario, Missandi,
and liberates the slave cities of Astapor
and Yunkai
Joffrey dies from Tyrell wine – another
wedding, nother dead king – Cersei blames
her brother Tyrion, in his trial The Viper
fights f'r'him.
Oberyn dies and so does Greg though Qyburn
makes Clegane undead.
Jaime saves Tyrion, who slays Shae and Tywin,
the Spider – Varys, sends the dwarf across
to Pentos
Sansa leaves the city with Petyr – Littlefinger
Who lies, wifes Lysa, then makes her fly the
Eyrie
Arya wanders round with Sandor
Kills some people who had wronged her
Hound gets bit by a bloke called Biter
Falls to Brienne when he fights her
Arya denies Sandor mercy
Shows some iron takes a boat east
The Nights Watch fights wildlings and Karl
fooking Tanner
Jon goes out beyond the Wall is saved by King
Stannis
Dany T captures Meereen, locks up her dragons
to make peace
Sansa marries Ramsay, thenorth remembers then
forgets
She jumps the walls of Winterfell whenshe’s
not saved by Brienne
Mel tells Stannis burn your daughter, and
it’s done
Then Stannis and his army’s slaughtered
by Ramsay Bolton
Cersei tries to frame the Tyrells
Ends up walking with a shame bell
Now she's gonna bloody pay hell
On the high and mighty Sparrow
Jaime comes to Dorne with Bronn to save his
daughter and e
Gets caught up with Obara Nym Tyene talks
bout “bad pussy”
Arya arrives at Braavos, joins the House of
Black and White.
She learns to lie, loses her sight, so that
she might become no one
Jon Snow wins a vote goes to Hardhome gets
some free folk on a boat then he gets stabbed
Dany fights insurgency from the Sons of the
Harpy,
tries a pit fight and a marriage, but they
both go pretty badly, so she flies way on
a dragon
Sansa escapes from Winterfell and makes her
way north to the Wall,
where the red witch is rezzing Jon – who
kills his killers, watch is done.
Ramsay Bolton expands his hold on the lords
of the northern kingdom,
so Jon marches armies Bastardbowl is on, the
good guys won
Arya trains, plays, saves Lady Crane, slays
the waif, displays her face,
escapes the Faceless, bakes, eviscerates a
Frey, and says she’s Arya Stark
The raven's training Bran to see through trees,
magic abilities.
Zombies almost kill them all but Hodor holds
the door.
Ben saves Bran and Meera, then says cya,
Bran sees a secret – Lyanna is Jon's mom
While the Hound roams round the riverlands,
joins the brothers' merry band
Jaime and Bronn break Riverrun
Blackfish would rather die than run
Sam and Gilly go to Horn Hill
Meet Sam's asshole father Randyll
They go to Oldtown, taking Heartsbane
To learn some stuff from the maesters
Cersei burns the sparrows, Tyrells, all her
enemies
And then because her son is dead declares
herself the Queen
Doran's slaughtered by Sand Snakes
So Olenna forges cause with Dorne
And Dany against Cersei's order
Setting stage for massive war
Then Dany goes back to Vaes Dothrak, barbeques
her persecutors, takes a khalasar, and marches
to Meereen.
She breaks the siege with fire, makes fast
friends of Theon Yara,
and finally, after all these years, heads
west, to Westeros.
Thanks for watching.
If you’d like some slightly more detailed
Game of Thrones explanations and analyses,
please subscribe and check out our other videos.
Thanks also to Random House for sending us
one of their new Limited Edition GRRM Boxes.
This is not a paid promo – but the Box is
pretty cool, it’s got a beautiful illustrated
edition of the first Game of Thrones book,
and the Game of Thrones card game which is
fun, and a nice map, and a heap of other stuff,
so if you’d like to buy one of these Boxes,
there is a link in the description below.
Finally, thanks to the Patrons supporting
this channel on Patreon.
The Patreon is currently paused, and no one
is being charged for the rest of the year,
because Alt Shift X is taking some time off.
We’ll be back in 2017, with heaps of new
Game of Thrones videos, and maybe also some
Westworld stuff, we have been reading your
comments.
So thanks again, and until then, have a good
one.